everyone has a different path everyone
learns differently and you're not gonna
discover the best way you learn unless
you actually just go out and fail
like I don't know if I don't [ __ ]
know I would waste like a month on
duolingo there's a lot of time on Julie
don't use foot like other languages
European languages I'm pretty sure it's
pretty good but I took Japanese it was
not very useful yeah yeah it was
throwing candy at you right from the
get-go light and not explaining why you
need to learn it or why what this sounds
efficient teaching me the kanji for
window like like that's one of the first
things yeah it was hard and like see
kanji for seat and I thought like why
you teach you this [ __ ] like I don't
even know the kanji for Monday like like
why would you teach me wind I don't need
to know that it's like if I do
everything windows in like the top 100
most used kanji so why you teach yeah
yeah it's pretty uncommon to say like
what like I feel that the way it when
dueling or went about it I'm not we're
never gonna get a Dueling or a
sponsorship by the way yeah it was yeah
not good I mean if we do you can call us
out on is await it like tricks you into
thinking you're learning no no well you
you know a lot of like this useless
parotid like pieces of information that
you can never piece together as a whole
- yes anywhere basically yeah and it's a
shame cause I feel you don't really
realize that you're being marked off by
dueling or until like you actually start
learning it properly
and you like I literally have no use for
anything I learn on duolingo because it
was such it was such a mess I remember
distinctively right like I didn't even
know how to say any sentences but they
were teaching me how to read the kanji
of Kyoto and Tokyo yeah that's cool but
like I don't need to know this like I
genuinely done if you go to Tokyo and
Kyoto it's written in funky it's like
this is something that I I don't need to
know what I would like to know is how do
I say like oh I recommend this yeah yeah
yeah I think it's I think you know like
I didn't know how to say I think or
anything like that right it's like I
don't need to know if this is a pan okay
I know this is I know what an apple you
know there's some good stuff down don't
say it's all bad but I just felt like
the structure was all over the place
yeah cuz I remember when we first moved
before we moved to Japan we were on me
and Conover on duolingo for like a good
month month and a whole yeah before
moving to Japan
and then we got there more like oh oh we
don't know [ __ ] so we need we need to
start off by learning hiragana and
katakana yeah and I remember we just
like I sat down and I googled like what
the best memorization technique were and
then ice I found this memorization
techniques like I can't remember what
it's called I think well like it will
link it in the description exordium Onix
like on um the exact pronunciation of it
and then I learned all of hiragana and
katakana in like one day yeah and then I
told Connor
yo this this this [ __ ] was like now I
don't know about this
and then I linked him to say Moscow and
he comes back to me like three four
hours later I'm like brah I could read
it was crazy it was like I said earlier
like it when you go outside and like
you've unlocked the world yeah you'd
stop suddenly reading McDonald's menu